I put that there because it's a weird
space and so now it's definitely not at
all distracting whatsoever no no no you
know your life is different now welcome
to a favorites video I guess this is
February favorite it's not totally near
the end of February but I didn't make a
January favorite and that's because I
haven't had a ton of favorite thing
snap seems sad just I'm trying to use up
all the stuff that I have before buying
new things but here are some things that
I've liked more than other things
recently yeah yeah say yeah yeah say
yeah yeah say this is Revlon kiss
exfoliating balm I consume alcohol and
so almost more than I consume oxygen
that's dehydration thus chapped lips and
I have lip scrub so you can make a lip
scrub yourself really easily with like
brown sugar and honey and stuff like
that but who's got the time I do I'm a
youtuber but I found this it's from
Revlon it's just little does that do it
it's basically this like chapstick
that's scrubby and you put it on your
lips whoo it's supposed to scrub all the
dead skin away and then I usually end up
eating it which felt a girl's bucket
over it you do it - it's in the flavor
Sugarman why would they make this sugar
mint if it wasn't meant to be eaten
like sugar yeah you get it anybody this
is super cheap and I had never seen one
like this at like a drugstore and so I
bought it and I liked it and that's
that's that look how compact it is you
next yeah see yeah see yeah see I said
put in a video recently I think it was
I'm doing Trixie Mattel makeup this is a
covergirl liquid eyeliner called
I don't know cuz I ripped off the
packaging 3:20 liquid liner it's like an
hourglass on a frozen PC in the snapchat
filter long walk to get there I really
like this liquid liner I'm wearing on my
eyes today Wow gotta brush so it's very
um any adjectives Helbig any adjectives
it's flexible oh I'm like a makeup
whoever watch whoa wow it did what it
said it's supposed to do but a lot of
liquid liners are really drying or the
applicator it's too hard
this I love well paint brush and the
color is super pigmented it fills in all
the spots and doesn't dry
and last for a long time I like it cute
next yeah yeah hey I'll see ya see I'm
gonna give you three seconds to try and
guess what this is your [ __ ] no this is
a face roller maker if I solve a jade
face roller yep you do this with it
what's why why why apparently these have
been curly these have been popular for a
bit now but I'm new and I recently
learned that this is what you're
supposed to use to roll on your skin
before you put makeup on and it helped
stimulate the blood and tighten up the
skin prepping it for makeup I walked in
the overhead for women red dress
collection runway show for the American
Heart Association and there was an
amazing woman named Nicole that did my
makeup her Instagram is actually in the
description of the photo that I posted
from the runway show on Instagram and
she used this on my face and I was like
duh she's this and then she was like you
can have this I was like ah what do you
want from me people are nice just to be
nice turns up nice people are nice to be
nice and so I've been using it because
this is so dumb I don't know it makes me
feel silly in the morning before I put
my makeup on and there's something about
just submitting to being a dump before
you put makeup on that makes you feel a
little bit better about putting makeup
on I don't know it puts me in a mood I'm
not taking myself seriously and then
also it balances out with god you're so
vain that this is what you're doing in
the morning yeah who knows maybe this is
just one long prank but I um you got me
you pranked me cute neck these cities
are glide scope outlast Floss Picks
I had a really fun day the other morning
when I went to the dentist and she told
me that my gums were inflamed aging
gracefully as always there inflamed
because I don't floss and so she had to
scrape out all the gunk in there my gums
are just bleeding like crazy and they
hurt real bad so I thought I should
actually do the thing that we all lie
ourselves and say we're gonna do as soon
as we leave the dentist and that is
floss and I got these because for some
reason my brain sees these and is more
ready and willing to floss than if I
just have a little thing of floss that I
have to do this consumer industry did it
again they made a dumbass product that
you definitely don't need but it does
somehow make you floss more than just a
regular thing of floss would you can you
see any a fancy no most of you know that
I have a dog named goose if you didn't
welcome to that piece of information
goose is a very high anxiety high
aggression dog no we were cooking one
night and the smoke alarms went off and
we turned them off but then a fire truck
showed up and goose ran out and so it
was like a whole struggle of getting her
off the fire fighters so for the rest of
the night she was super super high
anxiety and I remembered that I bought
this it's called my peaceful paws
essential oil blend I found it on Amazon
and it's essentially an essential oil
for dogs specifically it'll tell you
based on weight how many drops that
you're supposed to kind of rub onto
their paws or behind their ears and it's
a calming oil so I used it that night
and it definitely worked it works so
well do they think goose might have
gotten a little stoned awesome we're
trying to put on new sheets
[Laughter]
I found this on Amazon like I said it
had really great reviews and there's
tons of more information on Amazon if
you're curious at I'll link it down
below I try to use it in moderation
because I worry about potential side
effects I don't know but it's worked and
cool yeah
peaking of my dog yes Amy I'll say Henny
I'll say it if you didn't know I started
jewelry collection company called ok
1984 Joey Graceffa and other people use
that company as well and we created
these best Firenze necklace and pet
charm sets it's like BFF necklaces for
you and your pet and we sold out
immediately of the ones that we had for
the first go-round and so first of all
those are restock they're ones that say
best friends
and more dogs less people more people
less dogs but then we've added two new
styles that are so stupid cute we have
best [ __ ] available in little heart
necklace and a heart pendant and and I
love my dog I love my owner set they're
all available I'll link it down below
they are $20 per set and all of you that
I hadn't bought the first go-round I
have been seeing all your tag photos and
they're so awesome I hope you guys
really love them we got to know styles
as well as a restock of the old style
and we have so many more exciting things
coming up that I cannot wait to roll out
for you guys I'm just really excited so
click the link in the description if you
were interested in hey go check them out
yes [ __ ] yes okay that's it for this
favorites episode if you didn't like
this video give it a thumbs up don't
forget to click subscribe to this
YouTube channel I'm currently trying to
make videos Tuesdays and Thursdays we'll
see ya go it's consistently inconsistent
I don't know it looks like an IUD but
it's not I mean technically it's like an
IUD for your face protecting your skin
from stretching too much an IUD
essentially it protects you from having
a baby which causes your skin to stretch
not the correct comparison at all
whatsoever